wie wichtig es doch gurken
[Musik]
sailer keller messahli ist irgendwann im
jahr 1957 geboren
so genau weiß das niemand in tunesien
ist es damals nicht üblich geburten zu
registrieren
ihre eltern sind analphabeten sie leben
einen toleranten islam sich clark sie
das pulver und mein vater etwas herein
wie druck der straße was hat die
politische islam porträtierte und hätten
hier bietet es so ganz am schluss wird
religion des stars haben rückt der
politische islam leider nicht nur humor
0 humor immer mehr religiöse regeln
dagegen kämpft seiner keller messahli
seit jahren mutig und unerschrocken
kritisiert sie radikale glaubensgenossen
selber ist sie auch muslimen
also fragt öffentlich beantworten was
ist und was treibt salida keller
messahli an immer wieder vor einer
schleichenden islamisierung zu warnen
und wie kommt es dass ein tunesisches
mädchen in grindelwald aufwächst
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wenn es um radikale muslime geht ist
sailer keller messahli eine gefragte
expertin ganz herzlich egal ob es sich
präsidentin vom forum für und
fortschrittlichen islam durch leere
schiere zu der moschee und es gibt sehr
viele sony kunde habe mir absolut
schockiert herrisch ganz bestimmt ein
hassprediger so der diskussion begrüße
jetzt ganz herzlich sei der keller
messahli es ist kein zufall dass mir der
schweiz tritt sie nicht in den medien
auf helga keller messahli vorträge wie
hier an der kantonsschule burggraben in
st gallen sie eckt mit ihrer meinung an
und hat auch schon morddrohungen
erhalten
oft ist die polizei informiert wenn sie
öffentlich auftritt findet sie den
schweizer behörden gesellschaft ist zu
naiv
das finde ich vor allem gegenüber dem
organisierten islam oder und ganz
wichtige stadt zeigen dass der
organisierte islam maximal 15 prozent
muslimische bevölkerung wurde schweiz
repräsentiert das heißt dass die große
mehrheit von 80 prozent für die
muslimische bevölkerung nicht identische
vertreter ich und nicht über die moschee
verband organisationsproblem
es ist das problem wegen die minderheit
der radikale islam vertritt dhm
politischer islam vertritt wo eigentlich
die 85 prozent wenn die meisten moscheen
in der schweiz haben ein problem
behauptet saida keller-messahli denn die
mehrheit der imame die in der schweiz
predigen sei islamistisch das beschreibt
sie ausführlich in ihrem buch es ist
eine super organisierte angelegenheit
die moscheen wir haben mittlerweile in
der schweiz etwa 300 es ist also kein
zufall dass jetzt in wil eine moschee 4
millionen franken gebaut wurden oder im
netzteil bei glarus für vier millionen
und wenn wir zum beispiel ein imam wie
derjenige von will sagt ja die millionen
das ist das sind unsere mitglieder
beiträge
da gehe ich forsche ich will wissen
woher kommt dieses geld wieder keller
messahli fordert von der schweiz eine
politik der null-toleranz zum beispiel
ein kopftuchverbot an schulen ihre
gegner werfen ihr vor sie argumentiere
selber radikal und beschuldigten sie
auch schon der üblen nachrede für ihren
mut und ihr engagement erhält sie 2016
den schweizer menschenrechtspreis
[Applaus]
hier im hinterland von tunis verbrachte
zaida keller messahli ihre kindheit
die familie wohnte in einer kleinen
lehmhütte strom sie auch trinkt sie aber
mir erzählt erika und wahnsinnig
wahnsinnige witti und sehr viel licht
und sie viel leichtigkeit und das drückt
die landschaft da der vater war bauer
bei einem französischen
grossgrundbesitzer von einem tag auf den
anderen erblindete hier sei da ist fünf
jahre alt
der großgrundbesitzer meinte es gut mit
der familie und ermöglichte allen
kindern den besuch einer französischen
privatschule eine katholische schule in
der nähe von tunis von nonnen geführt
das fehlen der familie ist so schön
original blumen
das ist so der im begriff sie von der
schule da sie immer als kind
umgesprungen
irgendwo ist ein aufgang zum einer
kapelle
ich weiß es nicht so genau wo das gesäß
und also für hunde und paris ist das set
hemmnis volkswirten bereich sind
verboten der bereich beginnt und der
muss natürlich immer gefragt ja was
macht ihr da oder wenn er ist nicht
richtig verstanden
inwiefern hat sie das projekt das sie in
der katholischen schule gegangen sind
also das ist schon sehr wichtig sie bei
kontakt mit dem anderen aus einer
anderen religion in anderer form
ja und das ist sehr wichtig
vermittelt wurde und da ist immer diese
mails
also nie ruhe nun verkaufen
doch dann ändert sich das leben der
kleinen zaida radikal die schule
organisiert mit dem hilfswerk der saison
ferien camps für kinder aus armen
familien aus algerien und tunesien vor
einem jahr sind diese kinder aus
algerischen lagern zu uns in die schweiz
gekommen
arme kranke halb verhungerte wesen die
das kindsein verlernt hatten
wie diese kinder schickt man auch zaida
keller messahli als achtjährige in die
schweiz ein kulturschock für die kleine
tunesierin ja nach grindelwald mit
dänemarks rebelliert das ist alles
dunkel
ja ja ja und das ist schon ja das ist
ein harrison
so riss
[Musik]
was von der der sommerferien geplant war
endete in einem fünfjährigen aufenthalt
in grindelwald
die gastfamilie stellt den antrag sei
als pflegekind zu behalten
[Musik]
die verhältnisse bei der pflegefamilie
sind zerrüttet
die mutter ist alkoholikerin der vater
schlägt die kinder
sie verlangen dass aida mami und papi zu
ihnen sagt was für das mädchen nicht in
frage kommt jeder fühlt sich doppelt
eingeschlossen von der angespannten
familien stimmung und den übermächtigen
bergen
also es ist ein topografische schock sie
will janka von denen diese berge und vor
allem aber wenn man so dass sie dunkel
kat und die haben mir sogar schlafen
haben jetzt leidet zu machen
und der hat immer die schwarze wand vor
mir kann also als kind hat mir das angst
gemacht
das pfarrhaus ist der zufluchtsort
familie lampen hat für sie da immer eine
offene tür und nimmt das unglückliche
mädchen aus tunesien wie eine eigene
tochter auf sind sie aufgeregt sie ein
wiedersehen nach mehr als 50 jahren
familie lampen stets wieder nicht nur
während ihrer zeit in grindelwald bei
sondern unterstützt sie auch später noch
einen farbwechsel ja ja ja ja eine
erhebt die rolle von vater eine tiroler
ja das neue stimmen quasi wo mir gut
wort hörbar wird halte ich für mich wie
eine tochter
wer sich hier ist sie hätte verpachtet
haben sie verliert ja und die freiheit
an gespürt
ja gewollt ist bereits anfang der 1960
er jahre auf den tourismus ausgerichtet
ein bergdorf auf 1034 meter höhe wo
jeder jeden kennt sei da ist eine
intelligente schülerin das mädchen aus
nordafrika ist so exotisch dass die
einheimischen kinder am dorfbrunnen
versuchen ihre dunkle hautfarbe
abzuwaschen
[Musik]
es ist springen kann kann die hatte ich
sofort kinos und der bestehende du hälst
ermittler jena und die fahrten gewünscht
wie haben sie sie in erinnerung lebendig
es ist also schwierig da sie plötzlich
habe die familie verließ
4 mio humphrey tiger beifahrer diesem
samstagmorgen
ja und der hat das ist so schnell
gegangen
die mitschüler und der pfarrer
engagieren sich für sie da
doch die pflegefamilie schickt sie nach
fünf jahren nach tunesien zurück die
pflege eltern lassen sich scheiden und
setzen sei er von einem tag auf den
anderen ins flugzeug
[Musik]
es ist eine rückkehr in eine fremde heim
sei damals 13 jahre alt und ein teenager
kann in tunesien nicht richtig anknüpfen
[Musik]
red
die total verloren sie hat sprachen
können
und die haben hier sehr eines neues
schulsystem
also ja meine schwester die zum teil und
unverbindlich zu mir oder und zum ersten
mal realisiert dass mein vater blinde
denn wirklich realisiert was für eine
arm muss das mini ältere leben
doch sarah macht ihren weg sie besucht
das gymnasium in tunis und schafft die
matura fühlen sie sich mehr als tunesier
als schweizerin
nach der matura arbeitet sie als flight
attendant bei der saudi arabian airlines
sie verdient so viel wie nena im leben
wie sie sagt mit dem geld kaufte sie
ihren eltern dieses haus
könnten sie sich vorstellen auch
lebensabend verbringen
ich glaube nicht also schon häufiger
aber nach hinten natürlich groß
[Musik]
mit anfang 20 kommt sarah keller
messahli wieder in die schweiz zurück
und studieren sie arbeitet als
mittelschule lehrerin und heiratet einen
schweizer psychoanalytiker sie bekommen
zwei söhne
und inzwischen ist die großmutter von
kleinen
das ist
die fahren ja ein sushi bleiben
das haben wir gerade beschrieben im jahr
2006 der große verlust sei ideal keller
messahli es mann erkrankt an krebs und
stirbt probiere das leben wie die hand
sie das gemacht
ich weiß es nicht
das macht man einfach will der wille da
ist nicht im schmerz wir sind vor allem
eins für mich als mutter ist es mehr
umgangen oder sonstige dass sie trotz
der abwesenheit von ihrem clip der vater
vfb bietet sogar als mutter von zwei
söhnen lastet nun die ganze
verantwortung auf ihr seit dem tod ihres
mannes so sagt sie sei sie mit ihrer
arbeit verheiratet
fast schon wie eine getriebene setzt sie
sich für einen liberalen islam ein
was findet sie zu ihrem engagement ich
bin megastolz zurück was sie macht und
ich finde sie macht es sinnvoll war
gesellschaft nötig hat so und das macht
mich stolz sagt natürlich sieht er dass
es ja das sieht einen polit erkannt wird
auf der straße und so unterlegen
böse kritik und wo sieht bin ich damals
zum reparieren
aber das haben sie manchmal angst um
ihre mutter angeschnallt
[Musik]
sailer keller messahli ist präsidentin
des forums für einen fortschrittlichen
islam eine organisation die für eine
humanistische und kritische lesart des
korans eintritt täglich arbeitet sie an
ihren recherchen über den radikalen
islam biografie was sehr viel freiheit
[Musik]
und den ich nur so elan tag sie
unterlagen und in den letzten jahren
stelle einfach fest dass der islam mit
politischer ich wurde und dass ich
vorher nichts mit dass ich vorher
friedlich und absoluten nicht politisch
ziehen
mit der zukunft vorne zu rechnen man
muss einfach den moment genießen das
beste machen und zukunft die schöne
bescherung größtes
[Musik]